ESPN senior NBA insiders had busy couple
of days Adrienne will Generale ski and
watch joins us down the program loach
thanks for joining us what are the
pelicans doing right now the the
statement that came out almost felt like
they're saying you're not gonna bully us
into trading Anthony Davis you're not
gonna you know be tampering with our
stars so the approach that the pelicans
have now is what Dan somewhat defiant
now that they know they're going to have
to move Anthony Davis and I think
they're resigned to the fact that if
it's not a here at the trade deadline
it'll be during this offseason I don't
think they have an appetite to try to
bring him back next season for the final
year of his deal I think they know the
best possible package they can get for
them is when he saw as a full year left
on his deal right now between now and
the trade deadline next Thursday you
know they're gonna see what kinds of
offers come in and they're gonna need to
be bowled over to do a deal here in the
short term because they would like
ultimately to get the best possible
package for them and that probably
includes needing to have the Celtics
part of the bidding and the Celtic can't
be part of the bidding and so we get
closer to July 1 could the Celtics make
this trade in theory and then finalize
it in July when when they're officially
allowed to bring him in yes I I don't
know that they would agree to a deal
structure this far out especially during
the season yeah well once the season is
over
especially when there's draft picks
involved in Boston could have more than
one pick in this coming draft you see
this a lot where a team's drafting for
somebody else on draft night and then to
deal and or and then all the pieces and
the trade is finalized on July 1 so even
though they technically can't do the
deal until July 1 warrants Kyrie
Irving's a free agent they could have an
agreement in place well before that
what's the Lakers approach which their
game plan they're gonna be aggressive
they're they're gonna make an offer
maybe more than one offer I think
they're going
try to piece together their young assets
and some combination of them and and I'm
sure draft picks or a pick and try to
get this done before the trade deadline
next week there's a window here for them
to try to do this without the Celtics
really being involved but the hard part
for the Lakers twofold one the pelicans
are not dying to send him to LA and the
pelicans where the Lakers went through
this last year with Kawhi Leonard they
they felt that the Spurs never really
we're going to move Kawhi Leonard to
them at that time now the Spurs felt
like the offer wasn't good enough so but
the pelicans I think the pelicans sense
is whatever the Lakers best offer is
that's a trade deadline it's still going
to be there for us in two or three
months it's not going to go anywhere in
the offseason they want Anthony Davis
and and and Bill problem does assertedly
ante up you know like I said some
combination of their young players and
picked yeah I did the timing of his
announcement I found curious you've got
a similar agent with LeBron James but
the fact that he announced it now with
the trade deadline February 7th is that
just a coincidence no it's not a
coincidence and it gave them you know
given it gave them essentially almost a
two-week runway the team knew about it
over the weekend
you know we reported it on Monday
morning so the team had a couple of days
head start on it but that being said I
think they didn't blindside the pelicans
I think they felt resigned to the fact
that this was coming at some point so it
wasn't like they hadn't been thinking
about this but now it opens it up and it
gives the rest of the league a chance to
get aggressive and make their best
offers and see if if there is something
they can do between now and next week
but there's no question for Anthony
Davis
it gives him a window here to have an
opportunity to try to get to the Lakers
during this season I still think that
may be more unlikely but likely and I
still we're talking to Adrian would
generally ESPN senior NBA insider for
some reason and I don't know why it
feels like the Knicks
are gonna be a landing spot for a couple
of people in the off season and I I
wonder if Anthony Davis would consider
the Knicks if you have that high draft
pick maybe the number one pick overall
porzingis back is Kyrie Irving maybe you
want to play in New York does anybody
care about bringing back the garden you
know to prominence here yeah it's I
think it's a conversation among some
free agents I think Anthony Davis is
open to the idea now he you know they
had said yesterday they yeah it said
yesterday we you know rich Paul and his
statement to me was you know we want to
play for the championship contender we
want a team you know that you know was
gonna be very good going forward and
it's our ways away from that and you
know there's no question and in terms of
a trade trade possibility with New York
porzingis doesn't fit I think for New
Orleans because he he's he's up for his
route well he he's up for his rookie
extension or he was up for his where the
extension didn't agree with the Knicks
and so now he could essentially take a
qualifying offer and become free agent
the following year I don't know that and
I don't know that porzingis is dying to
go to New Orleans and then sign with
them that would make it hard for them to
do a trade I think the one way that New
York could be in this is if this extends
into the spring and the Knicks get the
number one pick in the draft and the
pelicans say okay is the number one pick
and a chance presumably to get Zion
Williamson is that better to us than
maybe
Boston who could give us multiple picks
but you know they're not going to be
they may not be top five or six and we
think we can mark it and and build
around Diane Williamson I think that's a
that's a pathway but I don't think that
is likely I think Boston can just offers
so much more in terms of picks and young
players and and and the Lakers have you
know a very Roop of young players that
they could offer up and there's going to
be other teams I think there's gonna be
other teams aggressive who are willing
to bring in Anthony Davis is a rental to
try to win right now and remember you
have them under contract next season you
know so you could have Anthony Davis but
the rest of this year and then a whole
nother year
give me the other big name that you
think will be dealt prior well that
could be dealt prior to the trade
deadline who anybody that would shock me
I don't I don't know that there'll be
anybody that will shock you I certainly
Marcus saw Mike Conley the Memphis is
talking on both players I think they're
certainly interest in both players and
and I think those are two players that
you know could be very impactful based
on where they land but I don't know that
there's a market right now with with
really any star player available outside
of obviously Davis and the two in
Memphis if you had to bet a week's pay
of where Anthony Davis will be in a
month I think a month I think he's
probably still with the pelicans okay so
nothing's gonna happen until the
offseason I think that's the more likely
scenario but listen a lot doesn't I I've
covered this you've you've covered this
stuff down it can change and there could
be some biddings you know some like
bidding war that gets going between now
and the trade deadline that makes sense
for the pelicans named in they may just
want this thing to be over and move on
you know part of it sometimes is
ownerships appetite for the you know for
the you know for the stress it puts on
an organization over a few months span
so you always have to take that into
account to watch thank you for your time
I know you're busy we appreciate it
thank you Dan that's Adrian we'll turn
around ski ESPN senior NBA insider for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]